hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to many of
us are familiar with exploitation
physicists the movies that take an often
controversial subject and what else
exploit the hell out now a good chunk of
the time the makers of these movies know
they're making over-the-top tripe like
jail sploit Asian films blaxploitation
films sexploitation films for sploit
Asian films I don't make major motion
pictures I make crap but the hardest
thing to watch are the exploitation
films that don't know that they're being
silly they think that they're making art
this is where the sale comes in directed
by tarsem no really this way calls
himself Tarson he is too intense for
last names this is one of those movies
that tries to tell you it's shocking
poetic and deep when it really just
takes elements from other movies that
are shocking poetic in deep and forgets
to give it a story and characters that
are actually shocking poetic and date
the result is a visually interesting but
pretentiously annoying dick fuck fest
that thinks it's saying more than it
really is so let's dive into tarsem soul
this is the cell so we start off with
Lopez of Arabia wearing an outfit that
looks like a melted version of Bjork's
Swan dress I thought we were going to
nailing today come on come on mystery
it's broken
who's Fez Moki look now it would read no
more Maki luck Voki luck is the
boogeyman edward no we got consumed by
those stupid scary face videos from
youtube so it turns out this was all
just a simulation to go into the mind of
a boy in a coma sang a song of sixpence
I'm guessing that's code for why the
fuck are we wearing twizzler cat suits
yeah this Nursery Rhyme thing is one of
the many pointless tidbits that really
have no purpose like why do they need a
code to know if she's okay
couldn't they just ask hey you okay oh
yeah and they don't call the boy edward
either for whatever reason they call him
mr. e get it because his mind is a
mystery this movie's pushing the
envelope he loves it when you visit my
husband wonders if that's true he wants
to place Edward in the hospital mr.
Baines I've been working on this project
for seven years I don't care if they've
rebooted the spider-man movies I should
be the wizard please don't take offense
dr. Kent
your work is invaluable to this company
but you're not sure about me we've
waited 18 months both signs of progress
18 months good god I pull out to give
him five more maybe they work their way
up to hey diddle-diddle we then cut to
our psychopathy for the evening
Carl played by Vincent D'Onofrio as we
see he spends most of his hobby time
partaking in you know I'm just gonna
make this a little easier for you folks
whenever tarsem wants you to be
disturbed I'm just gonna push the be
disturbed button are you ready let's try
it one two three be deceived nicely done
so what Lopez is feeling bummed about
not being able to work with Edward oh
I'm sorry
mr. e she does what any in-control
non-dependent social worker would do
gets don't off her ass
okay now we're just looking for excuses
to put her in pretty dresses pointless
oh thank god that scene will add a lot
to the movie we cut back again to Karl's
hobby which seems to be very specific
you know I'm starting to think this is
one of those really highly funded
personal porno movies that somehow
fooled executives into thinking and was
telling a poetic story you know like the
passion or the room it's not really
going in depth into anything is just
giving the director a chance to live out
his sick weird fantasies just like my
highly funded personal porno film
clown cats with six breasts from outer
space what will I find the other person
who likes this thought to be fair I
think those movies probably had much
more convincing long hair extensions
than Carl's baby doll boutique wig so we
cut to where Carl drops off the body and
the police look over the crime scene
the water always this low yeah this time
of year
give me a coroner's report right away
yes and we also had Vince Vaughn as the
classic obsessed cop how do I know he's
an obsessed cop well he sleeps and
brushes his teeth in his office he
whispers his understanding of the
criminal mind he's hunting he'd love an
animal like that but just loud enough so
that people can turn and say oh wow he's
tortured and the number one reason I
know he's an obsessed cop is he never
closes his fucking mouth oh I don't
think he talks all the time no no I mean
literally Vince Vaughn thinks the best
way to look intense is to just leave
your lip hanging open the whole time I
swear all I want to do throughout this
entire movie is go
but hey he has to look intense when he's
understanding a mind this sick for after
months and months of obsessing over this
killer he's finally come to an
earth-shattering conclusion that will
blow your brain there's one thing I know
for certain if we can't stop him he
ain't gonna stop himself
really what if we can't stop him he
ain't gonna stop himself really that's
the big conclusion you've come to I mean
he's already killed several women I
think it sort of goes without saying
he's gonna keep doing what he's doing I
dare even say painfully obvious what's
the next conclusion he's gonna come to
after all this time
all right people after months and months
of research we have come to the
conclusion that our suspect does
officially have hands oh my god what if
I'm wrong
but it turns out Carl does strike again
and kidnaps a woman from a conveniently
empty parking garage he puts her in a
location far away from his house but
thankfully the police figure out where
he lives
however he suffers a convenient plot
attack and finds himself in a coma but
the investigators continue to search the
place to see if they can find any clues
to the woman's location bubi dis dig
what the doctor fills us in on what's
wrong with it have you ever heard of
Whelan's infraction it's a form of
schizophrenia that infects the
neurological system in utero it lays
dormant until it's triggered by some
kind of trauma
he's not just catatonic he's disappeared
are we talking about the killer or Vince
Vaughn right now cuz to be honest I
believe either one whatever state that
he happens to be in there was a girl
that is missing if there were anything
anything so after he does the earnest
eyes thing he leads them to the lab
where the dream machine is located they
recommend that they go inside his mind
to figure out the location of the
kidnapped woman before she most likely
drowns in this death contract
now see how Carl liked to take beautiful
women and turn them into lifeless dolls
it only makes sense that they send in
the most beautiful woman they can find I
dare even say doll like to go in there
and face the danger I'm sure she won't
be at any risk at all oh thank god they
just happened to have a twizzler suit
his size on standby as they hook her up
to the machine and let her dive in
really you're throwing in a cloth with
Jesus's face on it I can't just see
tarsem dancing in the background
shouting ask me what it means ask me
what it means oh she comes across a
little boy version of Carl and ask me
what that means ask me what that means I
know what it means
Thanks and he leads her to a horse in a
laboratory
be this year
okay man I didn't believe that what
don't make me force you to write essays
interpreting the directors word yes big
we're disturbing than how they make
chicken McNuggets so she continues
throughout his mind as we see the more
disturbing imagery
I get this this really speaks to me
I know I'm supposed to be creeped out by
all this but this imagery has already
been put in a million music videos by
this point they kind of lost their shock
value even when this film came out if
anything it looks more like a tour
through pee-wee's S&M dungeon but she
finally comes across the center of nutty
town and decides it's too much for her
to take and exits the machine that's
right it's smoke it's smoke you're
obsessed that's what obsessed people do
they smoke but if you were any more
obsessed you'd be eating those
cigarettes he's had quite a journey that
could be dangerous what are you talking
about well if she came to believe that
starters world is real then
theoretically her mind could convince
her body that anything that was done to
it they're actually done like the old
wives didn't die in your dream to die in
your life sort of like if a movie
doesn't work on paper it won't work even
if you throat Jennifer Lopez in licorice
tights dr. Kent can I come in there
speaking better wake up we don't have a
lot of time do you understand that so if
one tries to talk with her to see if she
can make any more progress you don't
like what you do used to be an attorney
what happened
I had a case this little girl was
molested God will you close that damn
what if you're driving me nuts
Marvin stems buddy to be normal be crazy
bigger guy just try to catch him till
now
speaking of driving someone crazy wasn't
there a woman we were supposed to save I
mean what the hell happened - we don't
have much time they seem to be taking a
lot of their time right now should we
just cut to slowly sinking woman can
every time they say something that
doesn't sound important Oh Charlie beat
the murder rap because he was the same
any killed hey where the hell you been
oh right here well next time tell me
okay I don't want to disturb you you
look so cute you know you all sleepy
when you get that look on so Lopez
decides to head back in only things
don't go exactly as planned
yes because as we all know the killer
still deep in a coma knows exactly what
the room looks like and how to replicate
it in his mind pretty good memory for
something he's never ever seen before
quick begin trailer fuel so she goes
into a flashback where she sees Carl as
a little boy being abused by his father
things get even tougher when we
flashback to even more traumatizing
moments in his life like that horrible
experience when he joined the army
that plate
did you break that plate but not his
mother she remember that see that see
that it's true the child beating scenes
are really intense and pretty hardcore
but it dares to bring light to a concept
that we never would have thought about
before child abuse is bad yeah that's
about the gist of it
child abuse is bad because if you
thought child abuse was good before well
this probably won't change your mind
because you're already a psycho but
thank god it's showing the people who
already know that child abuse is bad
that child abuse is bad yeah that really
justifies this sad imagery but I guess
it's good to show that child abuse
always leads to psychotic killers well
okay that's not true but it does show
the transition of Carl psychological we
know about Carl anyway I mean there's a
scene where she's talking to him by a
bathtub and I just realized we have no
idea who this guy is we don't know if
this is the real hims a dark and the
innocent him we were never given time to
figure out what Carl was like in the
real world I mean we know what he did
but we never figured out his personality
we never saw him interact with people we
don't know if he's patient
charming awkward funny boring anything
we actually know very little about him
so how is this character study supposed
to tell us anything just that he was
beaten as a kid and he kills people I'm
sorry that doesn't make us understand
him it's like the story of Hamlet if you
were to tell us he was a young guy who
want revenge and his childhood was fine
what would they tell you nothing
you need to connect socially with him
that's how you make us feel sorry for
him that's how you make all this
exploitive bullshit actually add up to
something
you see what the final result is but
instead we get evil monsters to battle
but you know what that shit doesn't
matter if we didn't see how it affected
him in reality there's no connection or
understanding in this at all what fuck
it let me guess we have even more evil
Carl's to confront right
what's going on a hypothetical situation
I told you it's happening what a
co-inky-dink his mind is unfamiliar
territory and she's lost she thinks this
is real Henry
yeah no no what made you here what all
you guys do is point at the screen and
shout exposition anybody can do that and
once again how come nobody else ever
knows how to operate this brand-new
dangerous equipment except for two
fucking people don't you think there
should be more precaution for something
that they're constantly saying puts
people at risk all over my body
hey good good so Vince Vaughn decides to
go in because now again nobody else has
ever gone in outside of Lopez and he
enters into the lame tricks someone
interpret me actually I think I
recognize that reaction
it's the faces of the people who funded
this movie right after they saw with
their money went into okay so he goes
fine Lopez pretty quickly wearing um did
I miss something when did we get the
Disneyland so if one tries to snap Lopez
back to her senses not after giving a
little Jenny booty while he's in town
yeah where's that slowly sinking woman
cam again
but bad Karl number five drops in it
strapped him down to a torture machine
not turned on confused no disturbed what
bone tries to snap Lopez out of it by
reminding her of her past
yeah forget to NAAFI oh that's the
scariest face
you know her mind must be a real blank
slate it took almost nothing to win her
over to Carl side and it took almost
nothing to win her back tell her she's a
peanut she'll probably believe it
so Vaughn is released and he comes
across the clue he's been looking for
sort of gets out of the machine and
starts making some calls
what am i doing down there that machine
that he uses there's a hoist and I want
you to look for a plaque Carver
industrial equipment I want you to find
out every goddamn thing that you can
about that machine who used it who sold
it who bought it wait he had done that
anyway I mean we saw clearly that he saw
the symbol before
what did seeing it in Carl's head proof
was it just a reminder he should be
doing his job
Katherine open this door
but it turns out Lopez isn't done yet
she wants to go back into the machine
and bring Karl into her mind she locks
everybody out and does the experiment on
her own funny I didn't know she could do
it on her own I thought those two people
were really necessary but apparently not
she can go in very easily without anyone
else
whatever time to go back to lame section
Wow I don't know how they did it but
somehow they worked in the Virgin Lopez
this is an odd odd day ask me what it
means ask me what to eat
that's it I am so deep and deserve to be
talked about so you might be thinking
this is looking like the world's most
hallucinogenic Christmas card you don't
well Tarson will fix that what if they
actually add a Christmas border around
the frame I'm not even kidding
they put a Christmas border around the
frame what is up with these choices do
they even care what they're filming
anymore
merry Christmas from tots them I got
Jennifer Lopez to dress as the Virgin
Mary what did you do this year so while
one thinks he has a lead on where the
woman's being held it looks like we're
finally going to confront all the
psychological issues by diving into
Karl's psyche coming to grips with the
fact that his past does not determine
who he is or she just fights him like a
kung fu movie and rips his nipples off
thank you that makes me understand him
so much more so Vaughn does reach the
woman in time but Lopez sees that by
killing the big bad Karl
she's also killing the little innocent
Karl I don't know how it works either
but the credits are around the corner
don't complain good god boy so she
decides the only sensible thing to do is
to put him out of his misery
all right so you breach security defied
your superiors and you just killed
somebody who was in police custody
I believe we're looking at 10 to life
for that good lucky lady prison I'm sure
they make plenty of exploitation films
there so you should be right at home I'm
sorry we're operated by the movies logic
oh I'm sure you had a good reason for
murdering him we're just gonna let you
off the hook
no charges pressed any other bullshit
developments you want to throw our way
Ramsey told me he was thinking of
reversal with the kid that you were
working with yeah oh really
so the father of Edward found out that
she killed a man through the device and
that suddenly gave him the confidence to
entrust his boy to her again okay what
about you how are you
Courtney FBI a.m. you guys put me on
some drug-fueled mind bender which then
trigger the memory I already had and
officially we found julia Hixton through
good old-fashioned detective work
actually that is exactly what happened
nothing you said there was incorrect
thanks for everything but I think we've
both figured out today that we're not
very good at what we do
Pence's back in edwards mind they
finally go sailing the ad for her
perfume pops up because it obviously
looks like a commercial and the film
finally ends oh I don't like this one if
you're gonna do really hardcore risque
stuff you better do it right and have a
good reason for it I never got that from
physically rather than really trying to
understand somebody's mind or their
psychology it seems like they just want
to fool us with crazy visuals that the
film is saying more than it really is
now with that's it the visuals can be
rather impressive at times and the idea
of going into a serial killers mind I
have to admit it is pretty cool but it
has to be done in this case with more
thought and less instinct at least
someone like David Lynch or a Marc
Bergman who make very confusing films at
least give us a pure descent it is 100
percent psychological and emotional
interpretation this film either has too
much story or too much our team is that
it never balances out and it just
becomes obnoxious pretentious and
annoying I mean wouldn't it be more
interesting if we could really dive into
a killers mind and analyze it you've
seen my mind so oh come on
Karl just throwing some we're crazy
visuals at us doesn't count as a
character study well if you didn't get
what I was trying to say with myung-soo
and to me that's one way to confirm any
plans that's the bad I know that's
obvious but guess what the human brain
isn't that Simpkins it's too deep you
wouldn't get it anyway the human mind
isn't that simple he'll life is that
simple it's much more complicated
that's why we make movies about it where
there's one of the reasons about it
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have what you boys would
like some cool Oni
if we can't stop him he ain't gonna stop
himself
you